today's episode is brought to you by
M&Ms caramel chocolate candies
[Music]
from the studio known for confusing
lengths with death complexity with
intelligence and self-absorbed Downers
with heroism the DC EU pulls up its
biggest success yet by not doing those
things Wonder Woman after Supergirl
Catwoman and Electra Studios doubted a
female led superhero movie could succeed
now patty Jenkins bravely asks the
question what if a female at superhero
movie was an absolute garbage from
beginning to end and had a powerful
message for girls save the world look
flawless doing it be a literal God then
men might begrudgingly half tolerate
your presence sir if this woman can read
it we should hear what she has to say
yes very well
progress settle in for an origin story
about the Greek gods inside an origin
story for Wonder Woman inside an origin
story for world war ii the armistice is
of paramount importance and visit their
miss crier the Miss Korea the Emmys year
but visit Xena Warrior Island a society
of women trained from birth to cover for
gal gadot teased accent in the event of
an invasion this belong to the greatest
worry in our history you need to tell us
no yes but everything's behind that
corruption these Amazons have been
preparing their whole lives to fight the
God of War Ares and you can bet then
when war reaches their shores they'll
get rekt by German teams with
bolt-action rifles
hmm maybe send out a scout once every
500 years or at least deploy some of
your invisible Jets I know you have them
meet Diana a girl never actually
referred to as Wonder Woman she's the
hero the DCE you doesn't deserve but
sure as hell needs right now she's
optimistic confident iron-willed
vulnerable uncompromising and just so
hot I could say that right I mean I
don't wanna come off like James Cameron
because it's definitely not the only
thing she's got going for but damn she's
stronger faster and smarter than the men
around her but every superhero has it
kryptonite and hers is not knowing jack
about anything war what war it's a watch
toast time what for why are they holding
hands what did we mean we're into battle
does the average man not sleep
what is the secretary at the front with
fronted swats Mary you speak a hundred
languages you know what marriage means
experience this groundbreaking superhero
movie but not so groundbreaking that
they didn't put one of the bankable
Hollywood chrissa's in it Chris Pine
surprises and delights in a performance
that gives him his first lead in the
great Hollywood Chris off but he's more
than just eye candy
he's Diana's emotional support a voice
of caution and a love interest and
constant need of rescue hey they give
him the role women always have to play
against the male superheroes didn't they
I see what you did there in a film with
two grounded complex leads cringe at
villains pulled from a different much
campy or movie that seems to forget the
Germans in World War one were not the
Nazis one of the good guys
and those are the bad guys seriously
expects us to buy this human milk
thistle as the God of War and implies
that wonder woman kept her head down for
all of Hitler and Stalin but did suit up
the moment Lex Luthor made a ninja
turtle you know what I'm sorry for even
bringing BBS into this let's just let
this one stand on its own so get ready
for a film about balancing the good and
bad in all of us that contains good and
bad within itself in this flawed but
important movie that's no less important
for having flaws is it an inspirational
well-made film that finally gives women
a super urinal be proud of yes does it
end with a lightning hands mustache man
yelling videogame level dialogue and I
believe in love also yes
starring Amazon Prime want to touch the
Piney also the Queen and gladiator
princess cutter ah oh
party boy would you uh uh or apology of
a drunk Scotsman a sneaky Frenchman a
wise old Indian guide where are these
guys the howlin stereotypes Pam Beesly I
mean dawn Tinsley dun dun dun dun dun
duh and snider vision a Justice League
of her own
[Music]
maybe you're better off without me yeah
no Charlie won't sing for us um your
friend clearly has PTSD let him go home
thanks again to M&Ms caramel chocolate
candies for sponsoring today's episode
could this voice be any more epic I've
written so many comments but none of
them have made it hey no you're an
all-star I'm penny wise the dancing
clone be a bee why baby